with that let us bring in Florida
attorney general Ashley Moody A.G Moody
what message does this send to the wokes
of Wall Street
well as you know Governor DeSantis has
been very clear Florida is where woke
goes to die but this is a bigger picture
when you have these large Financial
Titans controlling access to Capital
controlling infusion of capital or or
control of of Corporations using that
power to social engineer some social or
ideological agenda that's problematic I
mean look in Florida we shut that down
here citizens were very clear we don't
want these weak woke Wackadoo policies
governing our state and so think about
what this would be like having Florida
funds in these large institutions that
were doing anything other than looking
at risk return and diversification any
other sort of ideological agenda it's
like a door-to-door Salesman coming to
your door and you're saying I don't want
that I don't like that I don't want that
magazine you slamming the door getting
rid of that salesman and then the
government coming behind it and saying
no no you do want that you do like that
and since we know what's best for you
we're going to go ahead and use your
taxpayer money to make sure that's
supported and get that for you that's
what's happening when these kinds of
monies are going into firms with these
other agenda other than pecuniary
interests of the citizens and taxpayers
of that state and so Florida has been
very clear we've passed a resolution
making sure our Pension funds and the
managers are looking at those fiduciary
interests only and I think you're going
to see us Florida continue to push back
until this is this is no longer an issue
here in Florida well thank god somebody
is because Biden wants this to be part
of your 401ks that's all 50 states and
that's scary attorney general we also
want to ask you about this the D.A is
warning that six and ten
fentanyl-laced fake prescription pills
are lethal so if you take a fake pill
and it happens to be laced with fentanyl
there's a 60 chance that you are going
to die and I know that your message to
drug dealers is if you deal fentanyl if
you traffic fentanyl in Florida you're
going to go to prison for a long time do
you think that that message is
resonating with people because so far it
feels like we're losing this battle
Carly think about this statistic you
know I've been warning consistently one
pill can kill well it's evolving quickly
into one pill will kill six out of ten
that's gone up 50 in one year six out of
ten pills laced with fentanyl are deadly
one pill will kill so you know I commend
you in this program for talking about
this as you know I've been pushing this
for years as attorney general law
enforcement has their hands full people
are dying people are being poisoned and
it's because of this open U.S Mexico
border I mean there's a direct relation
the DEA will tell you that the only
person that won't tell you that is this
Administration and Biden and I don't
know what we AGS have to do or what
folks that are concerned moms like me
who have had to talk to my kids about
don't take anything don't take anything
I know whatever you think it is don't
take it because it can kill you I mean
what do we have to do light ourselves on
fire to make this administration pay
attention to the fact so many Americans
are dying every day to point poisoning
because of their lacks and Incredibly
insane dangerous policies at the border
well you're right about that 96 percent
of fentanyl that's in our country right
now comes through our Southern border
and it is porous and that statistic
isn't going to be changing uh with the
president in office uh because he's not
doing anything about it attorney general
Ashley Moody thank you so much for
joining us
great to be with you I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis